we have 40 million slaves in the world
today
which is more than there were in the
19th century
more slaves alive today than there were
in the 19th century during slave trade
40 million you said alive today yeah
i've met slaves i've met former slaves
in africa and elsewhere people are born
as slaves a mass escaped
this is not an abstract point i'm making
i think that us
um beating ourselves up over over a
trade which our own country got rid of
two centuries ago
and if anyone should be proud got rid of
and um
and so on
there is
a significant likelihood we are not
dealing with for instance slavery today
because we're so obsessed with going
over again an issue that was closed two
centuries ago
and
you know it brings to mind a phrase of
nietzsche's in the genealogy of morals
these are people who there's a type of
person who who who tears that wounds
long clothes and then shrieks about the
pain they feel
um we're dealing with a lot of those
people at the moment they do not
themselves feel pain from the slave
trade they not feel pain from
colonialism they have decided to rip at
a long closed wound and then cry in
order to win something whether it's pity
or money or reparations or something
everybody would have their own view on
it but um i i refused to go along with
this idea that as i say
if everybody decided to take upon
themselves exactly the amount of
as i say it's a horrible idea hereditary
sin but exactly the proportion of
hereditary sin that their own society
was accorded then that would be one
thing it's quite another thing when only
one group of people and that white
westerners are expected to be
responsible for everything that anyone
who looked even remotely like them in
the past did
uh big um and everybody else is not i
mean the obvious example to give is
is a point of volt hair made in the 18th
century it says
said somewhere the only thing
by the way voltaire now is one of the
many figures who's been torn down
literally in paris his statue has been
now removed by the authorities in paris
on the great rationalist thinkers of
french society his statue was attacked
so many times by people throwing red
painted it that it's now removed and you
can't find it embarrassed nobody knows
quite where voltaire is today
um but now part of the allegation is him
that he profited through shares in some
slave companies they forgot to forget by
the way the voltaire also
wrote in candide one of the great great
um um
attacks on slavery but voltaire says in
his own day he says well the only thing
the only thing worse than what the
europeans have done
uh to the africans
is what africans have done to their
fellow africans
is what africans have done to their
brothers and sisters
we know uh from the the few memoirs we
had have
of uh people who were slaves in this
period people like equiano or lauda
equiano the most amazing man who was
end up so british and uh was baptized in
westminster became a free man uh had
most extraordinary life a man was well
worth reading we know from him that
friends and many many others of course
that uh he was he was stolen by his
neighbors
in africa
uh in the 1700's they um a neighboring
village they came and they snatched them
at night that's what they were people
snatches
and these africans uh stole their
neighbors and um and sold them
and um now
what is the moral responsibility of the
descendants of the people stealers
um
if
white westerners have take some guilt
then i would like guilt uh from africans
as well
uh what do you do about african
americans who are descended both from
slavers and slaves
um what's their guilt hereditary wise
they cash out at zero they would they
would come out at yes exactly
the balance sheet you end up you know
there um uh if you uh
uh one when i was researching the
slavery
section of this book
um
i got into the very interesting story of
the other slave or the other major slave
trade of the time of the time
whilst the transatlantic slave trade was
going on which was the arab slave trade
and the arabs had a huge slave trade
that went on for much longer than the
western one the transatlantic one it's
thought that maybe 10 11 uh 10 or 11
million people were transported across
the atlantic during the height of the
during the whole of the period of this
slave trade it's an appalling thing it
was a it was a
unbelievably horrible
trade which
people at the time most people at the
time didn't think was wrong because
people in the past thought differently
from us and almost well all
civilizations sadly at that point they'd
all engaged in slavery everyone
did slave labor how were the pyramids
built you know the the pharaohs didn't
do it themselves they didn't pay a fair
day's
labor wages to the people who who hauled
the stones for miles uh the acropolis in
athens was not
built by stones dragged up there by
arsenal willing
employees yeah i went to a uh i went to
a church in florence that was nearly 2
000 years old and it overlooks downtown
florence and the tour guide was
explaining to us i'm like thinking
this building's nearly two thousand and
it's been built up over time but still
the foundations are two thousand years
old and a lot of the the frontage of it
is
over a thousand years old
and i said well how is it that people
from so long ago were able to make
a building which has stood the test of
time he said well you don't have the
cost of labor
yes yes that's right that's right well
i'll come on to that in a second because
it's a very that's a very important
point um but just to finish that thought
on the the the arab slave trade was was
about um 50 more people in total
uh during the same period so if 10 to 11
million or so were taken across the
atlantic in the transatlantic slave
trade
it's thought maybe as many as 18 million
from where to were taken from africa to
what we now call the middle east uh arab
countries
arabia
by the arabs
the arabs traded as the europeans did in
slaves from africa
now you may wonder
why
therefore are there not um
more black people in the middle east and
there's an answer which was this was
actually a genocide
they um
the arabs
deliberately or castrated every single
male
so any uh any african male they took uh
to the arab countries was castrated in
order there would be no more black
people
um
now does that have a legacy to date be
sure it does if you go to
qatar
various of the gulf states you'll find
that they basically have a slave labor
class today the filipinos and others who
are brought in and have effectively
slave conditions i've seen it myself
dubai is the same dubai uh nobody like
fifa cares about this uh but this is the
case today uh in um in saudi arabia and
other arab countries the word for
a black person abid
plural abid
is slave
they still call black people slaves
my friend ayan
who's born in somalia spent a bit of
time in in saudi arabia she was growing
up and they were black because they were
in somalia and they were suddenly
blacker than the people in saudi arabia
and they were always called a beard
slaves so
so my point is not in any way to
at all diminish what the european slave
trade was what the transatlantic slave
trade was but it is very very strange to
live in an era where it is presumed that
only
the west was engaged in such a thing and
only we for the rest of time must repay
a debt which it appears can never be
paid down
um
and that brings me to what you were just
saying about uh what was going on in uh
countries foreign at the time i mean
didn't you say that the life expectancy
of a worker in lancashire yeah england
was exactly half of that of a slave yeah
working at the time the average the
average man in the north of england
working in a male
you know a mine
they died in their late 30s
so
i'm sorry
but
yes this is different from being a slave
but it's not so wildly different that we
are able to talk about those people in
the north of england as
benefiting from privilege
these were not privileged people
these were not privileged people
these these people did not have very
many life choices of themselves and
here's one of the main points to make
about all this is the past was pretty
much hell for pretty much everyone
i mean
even kings
died and princes died of diseases which
you'd now cure by a
shot of penicillin
[Music]
but the poor
who was almost everyone
they were not privileged people
and the idea that we have to recast all
the ancestors of people who happen to be
white
as oppressors
and the ancestors of everyone who
happens to be black solely as oppressed
is an incredibly simplistic game and
it's unfair
and that's one of the main problems
about it is it's just deeply unfair
and
when you find an unfair game like that
you should ask yourself
why are we allowing this game to be
played like this by people who literally
declare themselves sheriff what's
happening people if you enjoyed that
then press here for the full unedited
episode and don't forget to subscribe
peace